okay let's go next to our caller from
the two-five three area code who's
calling today from two five three hey
David it's Jim and I just wanted to say
a longtime listener first-time caller
loved ya and I just wanted to talked
about the green new deal and just see
what ideas you had about maybe getting
that pushed through and also a guy I
despise came up on my YouTube the other
day on the commercial Gavin McInnes on
this new show free speech and I was
trying to click out of it right away and
then all sudden I saw dr. Cornel West
and Marc Lamont Hill on the show yeah
and I actually checked it out and it's a
cool show in regards to just liberals
nailing Gavin and it was so awesome
watch especially Marc Lamont Hill I
cancelled my subscription because I saw
all the shows but I just thought it'd be
awesome if you could get on his show and
destroy him for so holy canceled your
subscription to what Oh I signed up just
to watch the dr. Lamont Hill oh I see
and Cornel West sure I I will have
something to say personally that I'm
involved with that affects me with
regard to this new Gavin McInnes show at
some point soon like I I don't I can't
talk about it yet but I'm gonna have
something to talk about related to it
because I've had like a personal run-in
with this program and I think it'll be
an interesting story as far as the green
new deal listen at the green you deal is
a broad framework so I when you say
pushing it through I mean listen right
now it's not going anywhere Republicans
control the Senate I think that there's
lots of good ideas in the green new deal
we interviewed one of the architects of
the green you deal on the program a
couple of months ago I guess it was but
as it is even if it passed it's really
just some general ideas and principles
without a clear roadmap of how to do it
and how to fund it so I support a lot of
what's in it but you know hopefully
after the 2020 election Democrats will
be able to actually start making some
headway on the components of it I agree
my friend god bless ya you're the best
and we love you brother all right Jim
thank you appreciate the phone call
thank you very much hope to hear from
you again